саміт україна-ес ще мій вигляд ніби 24
листа подаю брюсселі
станемо клич 17 йому двосторонніх вино
зонах лідери євросоюзу то україни
поговоримо про те про титри головні блог про
цієї безвіз прогресу переговорах і
аліса можу бути візою до 7 травня україна
вже давно ви каналу у сівби можу
євросоюзом вульгарний з монолог відмінний
підтвердив і про зайця єврокомісії
на дату України безвізовий режим заклав
всього ден застане ж формальних термінів
вироками
роду е100 європарламентом брюсселі не
хоче запускатися і без віз для України
так літак для грузії та інші crying
путін і навпаки її механізмом при зуб і
нині такого режиму все зі стимом
проти ти на ступнях уроку
теж на думку гряди чого реально
українці зможе і якщо ти даєш безвіз
не раніше лютого 2017
бо ще без ніша без т.к. та санкцій
виконання мінських ось одна з ключових
тим саміту так літаку продовження
санкцій проти росії за нексію криму
die на донбасі
chinese анти закінчуються 31 січ ним у
желе попарити додому нанести сир
відкрив є продовжить а їх членів Європу
офіційно що з рішення моєї буде і
ухилів рудні за словами експертів
Євросоюз програмісти гнутих труб це до
того як вигляд буде війна в Росії
дональда трампа 20 січня також видного
американського президента можна чек від
nsp діва на куполі тисяч диво росії
який він не якось фінанси
києва з темою переговори про
розширення доступу українських товарів на
європейські ринки то ви просто не
транзитних можна його стоїмо крим струму на
саміті травня буде і підтверджено ви справи
не українці 15 мільйонів євро на пит
ринку антикорупційної програми
а також 104 мільйонів євро для
адміністративної реформи
гілки відсікають практичної реалізації
реформ бо начебто бути корупцію а на
їхню імітацію